[Music]
as you may or may not know i'm always
been fascinated with television love
television you have somehow hit the
sweet spot i think you've created i said
two-thirds of the television shows on
the air right now
i'm very sorry
not just in this country but globally
and on other planets uh
incredible and in incredible success and
i understand i'm mostly interested in
how people get started how they get
their foot in the door you got started
in tv
because you were a door-to-door salesman
is that right that's right
i was going door-to-door selling
christmas crap
christmas well it didn't help that you
called it christmas crap probably do you
want some christmas called it radios
but uh yeah i i wound up uh getting a
job at animation but how does that work
you're selling door-to-door and it feels
like you just knocked on a door where
they happened to be working in
television or every door i knocked on i
asked for a job
did you really pretty much are you guys
in show business can i come in yeah
would you let me in you know it's funny
you you're joking but i actually tell
young people who ask me how do you get
started in tv i say go to where they
make tv and then do anything like you
sweep up well not anything
worked for me uh
but you so you go door-to-door and there
was a place that made animation and you
just said please give me a shot i said
what do you guys do here they said we
we're making cartoons i said uh you do
funny stuff and they said yeah i said
i'm your man i had no idea what i was
talking about i didn't know how to do
animation i'd never seen an animated
script before i was faking it yeah
completely fake and they gave me a job i
love that you also use the phrase i'm
your man which is something that you see
in movies but you think nobody really
says that it was 1987 it was current
then
so uh oh okay what what
what work did you do i know that you did
different animated shows can you give us
like when you started out heathcliff the
cat
you worked on heathcliff
the cat yeah
okay
muppet babies you worked on muppet
babies
well
i kind of got fired from the muppets
that is a badge of honor you were fired
from the babies i just didn't have the
the miss piggy thing going
what about my little pony is it true i
canned on that one too you got fired
from my little pony didn't have the
stardust star speckle
you could he he used some bad words can
i
yeah go for it who cares it's tbs man
yeah i have no idea what the rules are
if you want to if you wanna rip my
little pony a new a-hole go right for it